hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
this is episode 3 in our run-through as
Leon in resident evil 2 remake I get a
little lost in this episode so I'm going
to cut out all the 20 minute segments
where I run around like a headless
chicken not having a clue where I'm
going so we can keep the story moving
forward without wasting our time so if
there's a jump cut it's because I get
lost and nothing happens for a while
okay you ready let's do this
back in the police station again are
Marvin this is so much Marvin I left
some bullets oh my god oh my god that's
not a good way to bloody start me please
let see me pin to see me I have no idea
when they can see me or not hide hide
hide hide oh no how I envisage the first
episode to begin well the third episode
to begin I don't know what I was saying
now my mind is frozen by that attack I
think I was saying we've cleared most of
this out so we don't have to be scared
anymore we do have to be scared he can't
see me can he involve bastards
bugger off I don't want to be stuck
come on he's like why do you buy me he's
clueless the debugger oh I thought that
was the death animation nice where's my
torch here it is okay so yeah anyway I
was going to say welcome back to episode
3 in this one we are trying to figure
out where the little circuit breakers
are so we can get out of the police
station car park that's so much better
and I think we have a new roll of film
Locker code DC M DC Marvel that's how
we're going to remember that DC marvel
um aggressive you knew it I knew it
everyone knows it I say far too often
that's like ten times there was no
reason at all
I've gone down one corridors into the
last episode oh well we live and learn
boogers
here we go
cooking on gas still there Derek yeah
so we flying through this now she's
still there we shot her about three
hours ago
all right the code was d.c em oh my word
were almost we almost had it
no it's not what was the other code
downstairs was it cap yeah
[Music]
shotgun shells my favorite thing in the
whole wide world
Joshua won't be a moment darling you
don't wake up mister on the floor stand
on your face can craft some bullets
again soon not in nothing in their blood
I would be lost
so this is where the Stars offices yes
what are we looking for now USB stick
that's what we're after
oh it's one of these safes right so we
have to get the code in the right order
so it's just about figuring out how far
up so still look at three already okay
not there six three - no six four - no
no okay this time sorry for the wait and
we got a key we got the key
we got secret here we go we've got
everything now we can open everything
and that's two more for our pouch very
useful all right let's go and crank that
Soulja Boy
whoa see even when we've cleared
everything there's still little bits
then absolutely scare the bejesus out of
me how does a real one like you know
what I mean on the roof sugar oh gosh Oh
get out right
reload quick stay down and give me my
knife back
but thanks for holding it that's very
nice of you
oh Sh oh gosh why did not scan touch
this Paco
haha you only get one shot
I'll make it count who's the officer Oh
Marvin see officer of the month
Marvin yeah [ __ ] sir and we have that
crank crank that Soulja Boy even that
was bloody nerve-wracking new area see
you Rocco the music's changed there's a
basement we've got so much to look at
new areas are so cool and this was
booked love art key ok up or down some
more boards to grab must be something in
the lockers we have three flash banks
I know that there's so many of them so
many everywhere I just want this you
don't have to see me zombies this we
have a large gear good thing we got that
extra pouch subtly we're not getting any
altercations with the undead this could
be worn around this tanks corner of
course there is you did your new CV
Oh crud you bastard help go down it was
nice to meet you can I have it back
cheers darling
oh I'm so lost that's the heart key
again right yeah let's use this bad boy
okay so we can't use anything in here to
go we're on the veranda okay I'm just
going to pause here again what I didn't
realize I needed was just there did you
see it there's a little fire escape
ladder and I missed it completely so I
absolutely gone waste an hour of time
now running around but I did get a few
things and I'll show you what I picked
up there must be some way to bloody go
[Music]
I'm gay not you Tatum gain/loss do I get
Bob for those back stay down woman thank
you can I have both knives back please
no oh that's a shame what are you doing
love just gyrating okay
I've definitely missed something
this shouldn't be this hard I've missed
something Oh book this is for the statue
right get back to the statue room what
the hell's the statue room
he's a happy chappy you give me the
middle finger now that would be so cool
we have a scepter what the hell do we do
with the scepter this examinee of course
there we go we got a jewel I think we've
started the next activity before we
finish the current one I have definitely
missed something oh well
Hey oh it's okay it's only Linda Linda
you did scare me a little bit no you're
not guarding this plunge I can have it
Oh Linda listen Linda nice but do you
know oh [ __ ] [ __ ] this is not going to
end well alright alright alright it's
okay darling chill out
it's okay it's okay nothing to be scared
of
just me and you and your weird anus oh
and a zombie don't notice me please
he knows what do i do I don't know what
to do blow up when does it blow up thank
you
oh no we have to get past the door
please don't turn our don't let go can
you hurt me the animation yes you can
right we fight this through flashbangs
he did [ __ ]
still alive dead yet is it dead
yeah that's dead and he's like oh what's
the dinner room Oh
Washington's gone to pieces and relax
and we came here for some gunpowder
no is it we're back at the library where
the hell am I supposed to go
must be something we've missed are you
kidding me it's just a ladder that's all
we needed to find yeah you don't want to
know how long I've been ringing around
like a headless chicken oh well we found
it in the end
Jimmy Jimmy
do we pump this to get the water out no
line is broken water
we really need some heal spoo but it's
oh we aren't going this way and green
herbs we need herbs that sounds good I'm
scary in the slightest herb let's go
over them mmm I feel good
oh it's zombies trying to get out and
they got out why he got out son of a
[ __ ]
your son [ __ ] and these are two from
the original game
it's another Easter Egg you know God
asleep love so if we go into the boiler
room then we can put out the fire jobs
are Goodin bit of gunpowder should we
mix it now someone lose a key it's the
club key and you know I'm just gonna
save again because I've saved 14 times
and she's up again she's up for more
punishment I got well whoa did you see
that chunk looks so good okay let's go
put out this fire so hopefully I don't
know how this will work but hopefully
it's young work
yeah baby
so I presume we can just slide
underneath it now hopefully we will oh
oh it's you what do i do just go yeah
baby I get through the double yes you
can
right he's immortal Oh miss miss then
got fisted now that's a Friday night Oh
God Almighty two hits what are we gonna
do we're just gonna run unless you can
think of something else to do maybe we
can get past the helicopter did he move
the helicopter completely he did luckily
he's not as quick as us can he followers
into safe zones like this are we safe I
don't think he can come out here Johnny
now we're safe
are we are we safe I think we're safe
don't think he can come out but he's
he's in that room now oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ]
Oh God Almighty Oh you fast now right
well we'll drag him over here then we'll
go back through that door hi Marvin
good thing Leon can do the marathon he's
he hasn't stopped jogging for this
entire episode good lad
lost him oh no I forgot I'm where we're
going again I don't think I can handle
you walking like this for much longer
Leon hi neighbor
so I believe we can now go in here I
feel better already
Oh in the original Resident Evil 998
rust evil - sorry when you were in this
room one of the liquors would just just
look how he funded would jump straight
through the the one-way mirror two-way
mirror I don't know what are they called
oh that's lucky we did do the next part
without realizing we have a badge what
do we need this for you know the rule
examine is it USB USB alright that's
pretty cool
I'm impressed with that I'm so worried
this is all worried we're gonna jump
through this something's gonna get us
nothing yet O'Meara I wasn't expecting
it to work but it can't be it where's
the jump scare there's always a jump
scare hmm okay
[Laughter]
that's pretty cool
6 to the left two to the right 11 6 to
11 six to 11
six to 11 6 to 11 6 to 11
what's that did you have anything copper
gonna happen was not a manly noise right
come on then see if you can open this
dark as I can't it kind of missed where
I went literally one door thank you dude
oh you've had an accident we've all been
there darling
oh I sound like a zombie Rosie you went
through a doll do that you know what
just like it nope I don't have time
don't have time
far too scared easy whoa so we can go
over to the records room and we can go
upstairs to the stars office we know
this is clear what the hell is that tool
just like me good another anymore for
anymore
ooh shotgun shells would be more
appropriate mm-hmm [ __ ] he's near by
nine here is always in here is he in
those Egon no he's definitely not gone
I'm sorry whatever I've done team I'm so
sorry man and this is why we bought the
windows didn't scare me Oh sugar wrong
staircase oh it's okay this is main hall
again isn't it sorry not sorry
15 Adam you absolute [ __ ]
are you kidding I just want to go use my
tool in the library oh for God's sake
everywhere I go he's already there in
musical chairs mate right so I need to
fix the bookcase how the hell will I get
time to fix the bookcase well this was
the wrong choice I'm so special right
please don't be able to come in here
we're just gonna use the USB as quick as
we can what's in the armory
maybe it's the stock for the shotgun
maybe some self suppressor a blooming
lightning Hawk which means the magnum
rounds will not go to waste
letter to stars members to my bestest
stars buds how are you all doing in that
drab old station hanging in there
against what was that noise old irons
Europe he's amazing one month so far
blah blah blah blah blah Barry don't
come over here
scaring all the cute girls it must be
from Chris this Jill if Claire tries to
contact you please let her know I'm okay
Chris Redfield August 29 don't come in
here the dongle still shows up maybe we
should take him with
freaking nervous so we need to get to
the library we need to use the jack we
need to fix the floor so we can jump
across it straight to it know my scene
go go go
yeah boy right oh he's here he is here
we got one done oh yeah
pastor what the hell I thought he needed
stairs
can he climb up them jump across please
jump across are you soft demon where is
it oh my word he can climb
facts if we're quick enough now we can
move that over bookcase music correctly
go go go go go we're gettin that lay on
quicker than that we only only around
area please please please please thank
you go go go go go climb familia lass
the music's changed that's how we cross
what
he's up there
oh my god
oh my heart I'm so soft dry playing with
gears it's a fit that we've seen that
why are we seeing that
large compiler I guess we're fighting
soon then
oh okay
and then I presume we just switch this
out we make the clock chime which rings
the bell which knocks off whatever's in
that box which will be some sort of
mechanical device for the electricity in
the kennel area and the big bastard is
on his way back
but we need a third one to knock that
off we need a third
that's a big [ __ ] so if we get the large
[ __ ] from downstairs bring it back up
here Roberts your mother's brother
who is getting closely on you can't piss
about
in here not in not in bird
go ring my bell ring my bell three
o'clock
besides of that don't hope I don't have
to write a report on this uh how you
tell them jokes man he really is close
now right like always
what's in the box power panel electronic
power panel so now we just need to
survive and get back down to the analyst
two of them oh maybe we can unlock it
the time to we've got no time for fools
like you yeah you wish Dave yes things
are coming together at last
together safe six six to 11 11 to six 6
to 11 something like that I think yeah
what the hell is that a muzzle brake for
Matilda you take this girl yeah we need
you we'll get you some heels
you know what I'm gonna do while I'm
here I'm gonna say hey've we're going
for the world record of most saves in a
game 16 oh such a wet blanket okay okay
where do we need to go back down to the
jail
whoo-hah we're gonna say there's no jump
scares at all on the way down but no
good ol Frank easier for us alright pop
this in what do we do oh it's like
spider-man I have no idea what I'm doing
just click stuff for a while and see
what happens
right so two of these nodes have to make
it into the circuit breaker on the right
um stop guessing and think alright if it
goes round like that that's permanent
look around back there we go whoa
don't wake up we got the permit huh
what is he guiding sinkhole in a city
which by the way has to go straight to
your underground so we're going down to
the underground light oh look it was
this [ __ ] and you [ __ ] we can get out
what do you been hiding in here been
codenamed tyrant is not the one that
killed you mr. X chances are what order
to wipe out a thank you
this is gonna be hard now all these are
going to open at some point yeah here we
go ha ha expected it you didn't get me
that time resident evil do you know
where I am
there is so many of the Grenadier you'd
run faster either clever bugger calm
down what would your [ __ ] back
right just pull this to do whatever it
does what's the media well we're out we
got these no can we lock it we can't
lock it so where am I going
this is the way my game
Magnum does nothing to him okay
it's just a dead end
don't get my feet come on come on mom
no no dude it's just that you can keep
the knife keep the knife we need to go
always did it again
wrong way again please don't die
it's so difficult to think straight with
him just behind right next time around
I'll go the correct way come on Leon
we made it whoo oh we have a oh oh ADA
and relax this is getting old saving
your ass that's twice in the same place
- I didn't realize you were keeping
score look this isn't a game dies down
here
maybe now's now take it out the key card
yeah and this house hoping you could
explain what's on it
maybe after I hear it
let's get out of here
oh that was intense
we did it wow do you know what I think
we should end there because my high is
going to enter that doesn't who but I
enjoyed that
goodbye precinct I hope we never see
each other again
talk with Ada ok next episode we will
talk with ADA I'm out of a Playstation
grenade it's been a pleasure
take a bow Leon see you next time
you
you